welcome to your round six recap of the  2014 us chess championships while your  leaders have been caught Grandmaster  Alex lindemann losing his game allowing  version a cobian to surge into a tie  after a victory against alejandro  ramirez need to try to prepare well and  play well and on the women's side  five-time champion Irina Krush managed  to save her game against Tata abrahamian  leading to a draw allowing an asset on  ski to surge into a tie for first with a  victory against ashritha I swear on  zoton ski took the bishop leaving the  King caged in the corner and was able to  pull off a fine victories I'm try to  prepare to be in good shape to the very  motivated I think it's also very  important be sure to join us for more  exciting action of the US Chess  Championships here in st. Louis at one  p.m. Central at us chess champ calm